jetzt geht es in eine verlängerung die
mutmaßlich bis zum 20 dezember dauern
wird und sie haben auch schon gesagt das
kann aber noch nicht das ende sein
können sie denn uns verraten wie lange
dieser lockdown noch andauern soll bis
februar bis märz ist mir alle mit nein
es gibt ja zwei achsen über die wir
reden müssen das eine ist wir haben in
münchen lockt
deswegen dauert es auch etwas länger wir
haben den ersten erfolg erzielt es ist
sehr positiv dass die welle nach oben
gebrochen ist aber eben leider nur nach
oben
sie bewegt sich relativ stabil auch
gleich wo in deutschland bei
gleichzeitig dem anwachsen der
intensivbetten also der belegung der
intensivbetten und der zahl der
todesfälle
das heißt wir können einfach die zeit
und die uhr zurückdrehen und sondern es
macht wieder auf alles dies würde
bedeuten wir sind sehr schnell wieder
bei einem exponentiellen wachstum
deswegen ist es auch wichtig damit es
eben nicht endlos geht ich verstehe ihre
anliegen und haben sie auch recht muss
man uns nicht endlos zu machen an
einigen stellen gerade in hotspots
stärker ran gehen und dort das
öffentliche leben weit herunterfahren um
sich wieder besseren inzidenz zahlen von
50 zu nähern und die hoffnung die
perspektive ist ihre impfstoffe
entspannen ist sehr optimistisch was den
impfstoff bedürftiger glaubt sogar wie
ich gelesen aber sogar noch in diesem
jahr einen impfstoff zu haben zumindest
anfang nächsten jahres wenn wir dann
sehr schnell und konsequent und klug
impfen dann würde es die gefahren von
corona natürlich reduzieren weil es zwar
immer noch ein leben mit corona ist mit
einschränkungen
aber die gefahr für die risiko gucken
kann sich dann deutlich reduzieren
lassen
ist auch so die idee dass das was wir
jetzt machen auch dann so erträgt dass
wir dann in die google infos
hineinkommen mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bet schau dir das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren